[Musique]
bonsoir je m'appelle steven demers j'ai
20 ans si je suis venu vous parler c'est
pour vous montrer que le développement
de l'informatique
c'est un jeu d'enfant on sait sûrement
qu'il faut avoir fait des études avoir
des compétences en mathématiques avoir
des grosses lunettes à un gros cerveau
aujourd'hui à développer en informatique
c'est plutôt savoir rassembler des
briques
en effet la communauté développeurs
favorise l'apprentissage et partage on
peut s'appuyer sur les technologies des
autres pour ne pas avoir besoin de
réinventer la roue par exemple la
logorrhée de la reconnaissance faciale
celui qui permet de reconnaître votre
visage dans une image on peut l'utiliser
gratuitement et créer des applications
avec par exemple un truc essentiel
un programme qui pourrait reconnaître un
chat dans une image avec ça on pourrait
le nourrir les millions de photos de
chats dont regorge internet
ainsi on pourrait connaître notre chat
dans une image et pas n'importe quel
chat on pourrait même reconnaître mon
chat et avec un peu d'imagination pour
réutiliser un drone qui pourrait
parcourir et une zone pour essayer de
retrouver mon chat et me donner sa
position gps
retrouvé son chat dans le désert c'est
cool
mais ça va pas sauver la planète
c'est vrai mon chat va pas sauver la
planète mais imaginez une seconde
un drone qui pourrait parcourir un
désert et qui pourrait reconnaître un
touriste perdu qui pourrait parcourir et
montagne après une avalanche pour
trouver des blessés ça ne sauve pas la
planète savait mais ça sauve des vies si
ce que je vous faire comprendre c'est
que nous n'aurons pas besoin de tout
maîtriser tout savoir rire même pas tous
créés on peut utiliser ce qui existe
et ainsi on peut faire des projets
fabuleux comme si on jouer au lego
sauf que on tâtonne sur internet cherche
un peu et on arrive au fur et à mesure
personnellement j'ai pas été prédisposés
à sa personne n'est venue un matin
tatham apport comme dire que c'était ma
destinée mais c'est par hasard un jour
m'a demandé si j'étais capable de créer
un site web et avec envie de challenge
et dit oui j'ai pris le contrat j'ai
signé et entrant chez moi j' avais
aucune idée de comment faire alors j'ai
pris mon ordinateur et j'ai tapé sur
internet
comment faire un site web et c'est parti
de là après des mois de travail j'ai
fini par y arriver
le site web fonctionné et je suis devenu
développeurs en informatique on peut
tous on peut tous être développeur en
informatique taper une commande une
instruction
aujourd'hui on peut créer facilement un
site ou un blog pour votre passion qui
pourrait devenir une entreprise
on peut facilement créer un jeu vidéo
pour le partager vos amis on peut
facilement automatisé sa maison frappée
la lumière la lumière s'allume
vous rentrez dans une pièce la musique
démarre
et tout ça est possible pour des nuls
vous savez aujourd'hui c'est en créant
des projets simples qui répondent à des
besoins par exemple moi en premier
projet c'est un projet complexe
c'est assez difficile de s'habiller le
matin j'avais une petite chambre peu d
espace et je m'étais dit pourquoi pas
créer une machine automatisée qui ferait
tout ça pour moi on mettait chaque
sainte sur des wagons
et ainsi la machine tournait un bras
venez chercher des vêtements qui me
fallait
sauf
et ainsi en immergeant dans tout ça je
me suis dit que j'étais capable de faire
d'autres projets
par exemple la dernière création matthew
un robot humanoïde qui parlent la langue
des signes en utilisant les versions
existantes de robots humanoïdes
demain une fourrière
permettre aux sourds et aux muets
d'avoir accès aux informations dans des
lieux publics
ça peut sembler anodin pour vous
il peut même communiqué et apprendre à
tout le monde en parlait la langue des
signes
d'abord il écoute ma voix et la traduire
en textes et comme avec un enfant on
associe chaque mot a des signes bonjour
et des galas un ensemble de mouvements
et ainsi il traduit en direct grâce à un
algorithme nous développons et ne lui
apprenant
c'est simple aujourd'hui créer son robot
l'imprimer en 3d c'est possible et plus
simples que vous l'imaginez
vous n'avez qu'à imprimer montée est
programmée ou imprimés on n'avait pas
besoin de modéliser tout est disponible
sur internet
vous pouvez sélectionner directement
n'importe quelle pièce du robot et la
primaire
ce soir une statue comme celle ci un
morceau de votre projet un outil et
après des centaines d'heures
d'impression se retrouve à 24 ans plie
de pièces bon c'est un peu plus
compliqué qu'à monter qu'un meuble
suédois
mais grâce à internet vous avez notice
qui vous permet de pouvoir
on est tous là facilement et ainsi il ne
vous reste qu'à plus gros qu'un
programme est bon pour programmer
aujourd'hui on va vous faire une petite
démo on va essayer très rapidement de
faire la première page d'un site pour
une association de protection des
renards et ainsi nous allons créer
l'image avec sa source et lancer la
première image
voilà 5 mg la source le nom de mon image
on va réduire l'image pascal un peu trop
grande 60 %
voilà l'image est réduite par contre on
l'avait au centre donc on a juste besoin
de l'aligner au centre donc va traduire
en anglais texte aline center
texte aline center
merci on vient de finir et les stations
on vient de créer notre première page
ce fut si compliqué
on peut tous être développeur en
informatique aujourd'hui des milliers de
personnes chaque mois qui se rejoignent
et suivre des formations accélérées et
ainsi on peut directement se loger sur
marché du travail on peut rejoindre
l'équipe se lancer un freelance créer un
projet rejoindre une équipe en un seul
clic
une aventure aujourd'hui c'est possible
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est très
important de garder l'accès aux
informations et même les les plus
techniques comme l'intelligence
artificielle
parce que laisser le sujet s'accaparer
pas les grandes entreprises imaginez
bien qu'ils vont en faire que des
bénéfices alors qu'on pourrait en faire
tellement plus
comprenez bien que on veut faire des
choses splendide
1 je sais pas si vous connaissez le film
tout bêtement dans ce film la terre est
devenue un dépotoir et unique société
envoie des milliers de robots
des walis pour sauver la terre un qu'il
fera ensemble
j'aimerais que avant que la terre
devient un dépotoir nous puissions créer
des walis
pour préserver notre futur merci
beaucoup
[Musique]